غضب شديد والم عميق اشعل مواجهات عنيفه
وسط باريس بين محتاجين من الجليه الكرديه
والشرطه
يتهموا هؤلاء المحتجون سلطات بالتقصير في
حمايتهم ما ساهم في نظرهم في وقوع الهجوم
الذي اعد بحياه ثلاثه منهم وما زاد في
حلقههم ان الجاني غادر السجن منذ ايام
قليله فقط بعد ما دخله اثر ارتكابه هجوم
العنصريا اخر منذ سنه تقريبا استهدفا
مخيما لاجئين بيجو غصون فيه النوم دايسو
الناس هنا بالكثير من الظلم فالامر تكرر
بنفس الطريقه تقريبا في المنطقه نفسها
وهذا ما يجعل هؤلاء يشعرون بالحزن والغضب
عالم اذا كما نشاهد من الان في وسط باريس
هدف مواجهات عنيفه بين الشرطه والمتظاهرين
الاكراد الشرطه تطلق الغاز المسير للدموع
بكثافه على الف متظاهرين في هنا وسط باريس
وكما نشاهد هجوم من قبل قوات الشرطه
لمحاولته ايقافه هؤلاء
المحتاجين هنا على خلفيه الهجوم الدامي
وسط العاصمه باريس
اعاده هذه الاحتجاجات الجدل بشان تطرف
اليمني في فرنسا الى الواجهه فنددت شخصيات
اياساريه بما اعتبرته تطبيعا وتساهلا مع
الخطاب العنصري خلال السنوات الاخيره ما
ادى في نظرها الى تطور الامور لتصل حد
الهجمات المسلحات القاتله
صغير مقبول ان تتحول باريس الى ارض خطيره
على الاكراد لن نقبل ان تكون باريس
واحياءها المختلطه الاعراق والثقافات ارضا
تخيف الاكراد
لم تكون مثل هذه الخطابات التضامنيه كافيه
وحدها على ما يبدو للتخفيف من شده الغضب
هنا ما دفع هؤلاء للمطالبه بتصنيف الهجوم
على مركزهم الثقفي جريمه ارهابيه
واغتيالات سياسيه ولا احد يشك اليوم في ان
استهداف جمعيتنا بهذه الطريقه هو عمل
سياسي ارهابي لهذا طالبنا باعاده تكييف
الجريمه من جديد
تظهر المؤشرات وان الهجوم الاخيره قد يكون
له ما بعده سياسيا واخلاقيا ايضا في ظل
صمت مدون للكثير من الاصوات السياسيه
اليمنيه التي دابت على تصدر المشهد مع كل
هجوم تعرفه فرنسا حافظ ربح الجزيره باريس